bon alors c'est pas de la rigolade ah
non pas du tout on va passer au blind
test mesdames messieurs une cantine
ces mini dans notre vie minimum
minimes filles
c'était
attention attention aux ravages de
marcia soufflage ya très bien en suisse
est habilité spéciale gens de petite
taille en hommage à jamel qui prépare le
blind comprends pas pourquoi ce en
hommage à moi mais didier vous effraie
alors on est bien d'accord pascal sevran
vous êtes un spécialiste passer si on va
passer tout ce que vous aimez c'est des
nains on va passer on m'appelle ses
collègues de reals bas c'est très bien
lucienne delyle très bien lucienne boyer
très bien voilà didier
m
voilà une canne est en jeu du prime de
la star ibère est le père et framboise
jusqu'idi gi joe the raveonettes mois
qui viennent bah il sort trois films par
an même temps que l'année alors chanson
numéro 2
bordeaux
tu fait croquer la pomme elle pense
qu'elle s'est installée alors tout le
monde veut que je suis interviews et où
je pense que bientôt je vous ai
interviewé pendant lé très petit elle
sonne le blind test on va paraître jean
petit et en hommage à jamel debbouze et
à ma femme d'accord allait petit à petit
les plus grandes personnes son petit
chez les paniers les gens qu'on a pâti
monnaie.ca elizabeth taylor en m 58
alain giresse ahmed 56 bien sûr et
calculs justement ça dommage qu'on va en
petit ou là c'est pour montrer que les
faits sont des génériques
et là je suis dj
commencez la chanson que l'on touche à
la liberté et paris se met en colère
ces très jeunes gens sont très jolies
chansons gérant cet effet pour pascal
sevran ça pas manquer didier
talus à gmail talia pouvez vous éloignez
non ce qu'il ya un lien tout seul c'est
autre chose
trichet vous souffrez vous enlevez avec
morales à la dalle est normalement oui
on ne peut pas bien voilà tally à chaque
fois vous trichez legend est un vêtement
du passo veulent faire
bien sûr ça les gens revanche amusez
vous bien continue
là
l'exécutif je voudrais que la jeune
fille qu'elle a en led sont une au vert
je vous demande de vous arrêter là
heureusement qu'il est là et doit quoi
berman les verbes n 5 et les rouges
alors là ce qui se passe on ne comptait
pas assis à leur visite à sa fille qu'on
me pousse think you are c'est quand elle
souffre alors oui 2.2.2 vois pas ce qui
se passe je suis moi il n'y a pas eu
barry white une fois depuis tout à
l'heure il n'y a pas eu son pote barry
white gens connaissent et jackson si
c'est ta copine rihanna tension sur le
cac c'est exact bien on continue didier
6 à 2 bravo bio alors n'allez quand même
pas dire elle a soufflé mais il a dit
avant
ces crédits comme à l'habitude de crier
tout leuthard doit aller sur le nom
d'abord interné en fait un petit rifle
et serge un petit replay s'il vous plaît
certes certes
à la clé l internet alors catherine
barma me dit chez astrid veillon ou
serge khalfon me dis que c'est
générationnel
j'ai dit le non halal mais quand je
pense que j'ai bien vous avez une belle
doit la première mais le mot michel
jonasz et sortir les gens lèvent
l'oreillette parce qu'ils se disputent
en régie voilà oui tout ne s'achète pas
s'il vous plaît alors je disais je pense
qu'il ya eu tricherie
le cabinet est un bien très bien le
tablier
thallion d'aliens le tapis du patriciat
attention c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
didier
tours sont fausses les écoles n'ont ils
écoutés
pettis l'ami délice mais je vous en prie
ch
on écoute monsieur l'académicien s'il
vous plaît j'ai pas compris un mot mais
une équipe à laquelle j'ai pas
là on continue jeta la passion
via
les zooms
en même temps c'est normal vous ne vous
défendez la grande chanson française
pascal leroy et miliband et chantal goya
fous de ma gueule et chassent la bourse
et quoi passer d'accord et mireille
mathieu demy dévié et sammy davis junior
et je peux vouloir faire d'autres et qui
saisit les a trouvés c'est vrai ce cas
c'est moi qui gagne le plus
ouais c'est vrai je crois j'attends joue
pas jusqu'à l'incroyable non plus par ma
faute d'accord djamel avec thibault
s'est alors je cherche des cas des notes
alors bol d'or charles aznavour je
connais la moitié de ces chansons là
prête
après j'avais 20 ans et un petit peu
mais là je sais pour jean-christophe
bien alors on continue
peut-être
à lui nous allions je suis désolé d'y
insister braves gens juge est tenu par
une équipe formidable parce que sevran
veillon des cannes est mort d'anna c'est
vrai dans l'équipe gagnante de la fois
qu'ils jouent ya ceux qui joueront gros
mais on continue je kif avec un sac
voilà
non énorme
donc c'est vrai que ma fille on peut
penser qu'ils que les biens ma femme
voire cas plus si affinités mais vous
non donc je la fais quoi moi j'ai sonné
c'est grâce à arthur moi qui connais
merci arthur donc bravo ça c'est très
fort d'avoir trouvé dans ce gala
l'orgasme énorme à la première mais j'ai
chanté sur france galles pendant des
mois la wii quand j'étais môme je jouais
du piano de pauvres et pour moi sous vos
yeux
cela veut dire qu'il est est libre nous
occasionne chinois dimanche midi 1
ouais à dimanche midi ou bien à 12h05
sur france 2 sera bien oui elle encore
émue et celui des services est passé
déclaré j'allais j'allais arrêter la
musique ce que j'allais arrêter la
musique pour écouter jean d'ormesson
mais vraiment la première note vous
l'avez russell 1 voulait dire quoi gens
mais je voulais vous demander à vous à
vous si vous vouliez faire quelque chose
au foyer la fourrure avec vous bon
maintenant mauvaise ou très mauvaise
nouvelle parce que maintenant bon c'est
vrai que les verts ils en sont à 12 et
des rouges ils en sont à 2 mais
maintenant il ya le super banco et le
super banco chez dams interviendra ce
jeu super héros super banco serre que
celui qui trouve le super bons coups il
a gagné c'est injuste mais bien sûr vous
le savez la vie est un témoin de la
place il est capable
alors le super bon coup je le dis tout
de suite c'est très très dur on peut
vous éloignez non non non non vous vous
éloignez excusez moi je vous demande
vraiment à lire et vous éloigner
j'ai pas envie d'avoir vous écarter un
dieu j'ai par une finition après le non
plus donc vous c'est pas le genre de
l'émission n'ont pas lu toujours bien
alors attention
non mais je sais elle me trichet le
sujet laterrière attention talia voilà
attention c'est très important c'est
comme une finale de coupe du monde de
football attention vous êtes prêts
didier
l'entraîneur
deux maîtres énorme et mal
à
elle
élan à l'essor évidemment l'adaptation
de chimène skarn d'aline de family par
les soeurs qui étaient de jeunes
malgaches qui était très petit aussi de
dire la météo les soeurs vidéo comme ça
les a bien trouvé la réponse à avoir
connu falabracs en peu de lettres mozart
sans savoir messieurs ont fait comme
mozart mais fallait bien sûr
donc c'est un peu mauvais perdant
l'aller 2-1 tab moi je dis que pour
répondre à pascal sevran messieurs donc
raison de plus
et chanter la vie demain pour compenser
ce manque est bien